we've learned a little bit already about
how a production possibilities curve can
be used to illustrate the concept of
economic growth let's review the
definition of economic growth then we're
going to go into some more depth about
the trade-offs that society faces today
between the production of different
types of goods and how that can affect
the level of economic growth in the
future
you'll recall that economic growth
is defined as an increase in the ability
of a nation to produce goods and
services over time
you've already learned that in the
production possibilities curve model
economic growth can be illustrated as a
shift outward in the nation's ppc over
time in the graph on our left here
economic growth would be shown as a
shift from the white curve
to the pink curve this represents an
increase in the ability of a nation to
produce both the goods shown on its ppc
over time the question we want to
discuss is what are the sources of
economic growth and how does a nation's
decision about how to allocate its
resources today affect its level of
potential output in the future
to help us answer this question we're
going to put some different goods on our
production possibilities curve here
and for today's lesson we'll be looking
at
two types of goods
the rubber ducky on the vertical axis
represents what we're going to call
consumer goods we're going to define
these in just a moment let's look down
at the horizontal axis first
the tractor here it's a tool this is a
good that is used to produce other goods
it's used to produce agricultural
products which could be used to produce
all sorts of goods the society needs a
tractor and any other tools like
tractors are what we call capital goods
let's define consumer goods and capital
goods before moving on with our analysis
a rubber ducky in our ppc is a consumer
good this is a good intended to be sold
to households consumer goods are used
for consumption
and ultimately consumer goods are
disposed of
how does this contrast with capital
goods though
capital goods are a bit different
capital goods are any goods
sold to firms
capital goods unlike consumer goods are
used
to produce other goods
therefore if society allocates more
resources towards capital goods today
society is essentially choosing to
produce more goods and services in the
future and the trade-off being less
goods and services produced today
so let's look back at our white ppc here
let's assume that this represents
today's production possibilities for a
hypothetical country
a country can choose to produce more
consumer goods today
by doing so it would be producing at a
point such as point a notice that at
point a
countries producing more rubber duckies
but the opportunity cost is
the capital goods or the tools that it
could be producing instead
or society can choose to allocate its
resources at a point such as point b
allocating its resources at point b
means society is choosing to produce
more capital goods today
with the opportunity cost being fewer
consumer goods
notice that if a country were to move
from point a
to point b
it would give up
all these rubber duckies all the toys
all the consumer goods
that it could have produced if it had
chosen to produce a point a instead
so this is the opportunity cost
of producing a point b
now what if society moved in the other
direction
and chose to produce
more consumer goods today what if
society went from point b
to point a in other words well in that
case the opportunity cost would be the
capital goods
that it could have enjoyed if it had
chosen to produce a point b
the ppc once again illustrates this very
basic concept of opportunity cost it
shows us what is given up in order to
have anything
so let's do some analysis over here of
the consequences of this country
choosing to produce a point a
or
choosing to produce at point b
what happens if society chooses to
allocate more resources towards consumer
goods today
essentially what it's choosing is
current consumption
of goods and services
over
future consumption
what do i mean by this
essentially by producing at point a
society is giving up all those capital
goods that could have been used to
produce other goods in the future
therefore society is choosing a higher
standard of living today rather than a
higher standard of living sometime in
the future
let's contrast that with point b
on our production possibilities curve if
society chooses to allocate more
resources towards capital goods today
society is choosing future consumption
over
current consumption
what do we mean by that by allocating
more of its scarce resources towards
capital goods and tools and equipment
and technology that can be used to
produce other goods today society is
giving up the current consumption that
it could enjoy by producing more toys or
consumer goods today
the benefit though the benefit of
producing more capital goods today
is likely to be higher rates of economic
growth in the future
why is that the case because capital
goods are those things which are used to
produce other goods capital is a factor
of production consumer goods are not a
factor of production consumer goods are
fun to consume they're fun to enjoy we
love playing with their toys but
ultimately they get consumed and thrown
away capital goods aren't quickly
disposed of they instead are used in
factories they're used in the fields
they're used in the mines they're used
in all the different ways that we
produce goods and services that society
benefits from
by allocating more resources towards
capital goods today a country would be
choosing future consumption over current
consumption now to illustrate this
concept we can look at some real world
data what i'm about to show you is some
data for two countries that shows how
those countries are choosing to allocate
the resources today
we can then compare the rates of
economic growth over the last 15 years
to show that one of those countries has
in fact experienced higher rates of
economic growth
let's look at our data first
here we've got the
output data of two countries china on
the left and the united states on the
right what can we learn from this
information
first let's look at china notice that in
2016 the year for which this data
applies china invested 43 percent of its
entire gdp
what does that mean it means that 43.7
dollars out of every hundred dollars
spent in china was spent on
capital goods
compare that to
the level of consumption in china only
37 percent
of china's total spending went towards
household consumption
china is choosing to allocate more of
its resources towards the production of
capital goods than it is towards the
production of consumer goods
let's look over at the united states in
the united states in 2016
only 15.9 percent
of total spending went towards capital
goods on the other hand 68.6 percent
of america's total spending went towards
you guessed it household consumption
america has essentially chosen rubber
duckies over tractors or consumer goods
over capital goods
so this is one data point it's not the
only thing that affects the rates of
economic growth in a country but if we
look at the actual rates of economic
growth since the year 2000
for china and the united states
an interesting fact emerges
china has enjoyed significantly higher
rates of economic growth
the blue line here represents china's
economic growth rates from 2000
to 2015
and we can see that china has average
rates of economic growth of between
and 14
per year that means that every year
china's economy has produced
approximately 10 percent more stuff than
it did the year before compare that to
the united states in the united states
growth rates have averaged between
negative two percent
and four percent significantly lower the
united states has achieved economic
growth for most of the last 15 years but
the rate of economic growth was quite a
bit lower than china china has of course
a much larger population also china is
at a lower level of economic development
than the united states so it has more
room to grow there are more unused
resources in china but that aside
china also chooses to allocate more of
its resources towards investment in
capital goods than it does production of
consumer goods for households this fact
going back to our production
possibilities curve supports the idea
that by choosing to produce more capital
goods today a country is essentially
choosing future consumption over current
consumption economic growth has many
causes economists have been discussing
the source of economic growth for over
200 years now increases in the
population increases in the education
level the skill level the amount of
technology and the availability of
resources are significant sources of
economic growth however a country's
decision as to how it allocates its
resources today also impacts its rate of
economic growth